meine damen und herren wir sind heute
erneut zusammengekommen um über die roma
pandemie und das gemeinsame management
dieser pandemie untereinander zu beraten
für uns alle ist klar dass die
richtung die wir eingeschlagen haben
hilft dass sie dazu beigetragen habe
dass wir die bewohner pandemie in
deutschland in der gegenwärtigen
situation anders bewältigen können als
viele unserer nachbarländer und das ist
das so wichtig ist diesen kurs
fortzusetzen
dazu wird zuallererst dass wir in
deutschland sehr strenge kontakt
beschränkungen haben die notwendig sind
für die zusammenkünfte im privaten
bereich für den zugang zu geschäften zu
restaurants zur veranstaltung zu
gefallen was dazu führt dass viele
menschen miteinander zusammen kommen und
deshalb natürlich auch die
ansteckungsgefahr damit erhöhen bleibt
diese regelung haben dazu beigetragen
dass bei uns die hohen infektionszahlen
die uns noch ende letzten jahres
vorhergesagt worden sind erst jetzt
erreicht worden sind viel später als in
vielen nachbarländern
trotzdem sind es sehr hohe
infektionszahlen und deshalb gilt für
uns auch dass wir unverändert vorsichtig
bleiben müssen und diesen kurs auch
beibehalten werden darauf haben sich
bund und länder in dieser zusammenkunft
miteinander verständigt wir wissen noch
nicht wie sich die infektion weiter
entwickeln werden ob wir mit einer
dramatischen situation noch rechnen
müssen im zusammenhang mit den
steigenden infektionszahlen durch die
hoch ansteckende omikron variante oder
ob wir bald schon sehen können dass wir
ganz gut durch diese zeit kommen in
beiden fällen und in beide richtungen
werden wir dann zur richtigen zeit die
notwendigen entscheidungen treffen jetzt
aber gilt erstmal kurs halten
das zweite was wir in dieser situation
großer anstrengung auf den weg gebracht
haben ist eine neue kampagne zum impfen
und postern in deutschland wir hatten
uns vor weihnachten vorgenommen bis
weihnachten 30 millionen impfungen zu
erreichen das ist auch gelungen und wir
fahren unverändert fort möglichst viele
davon zu überzeugen dass sie sich eine
auffrischungsimpfung holen das tempo hat
nachgelassen das ist etwas was wir
konstatieren müssen trotzdem geht es
voran sowohl mit dem ersten als auch mit
den auffrischungsimpfungen und wir schon
eine hohe zahl von bürgern und bürgern
erreicht haben und das soll jetzt in den
nächsten tagen und wochen weitergehen
dass aber die bundesregierung auch im
übrigen sich entschlossen ihre werbliche
kampagne in diesem zusammenhang noch
einmal neu aufzulegen sie sehen hinter
mir impfen hilft das ist nur ein ganz
kleiner auszug von dem was wir uns
vorgenommen haben es kommen noch viele
viele andere dazu vom radio spot zur
benutzung der
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten die sich mit
social media verbinden und alles
zusammen soll dazu beitragen dass die
zahl derjenigen die sich jetzt
entschließen sich das erste mal impfen
zu lassen und die zahl derjenigen die
sich jetzt eine auffrischungsimpfung
kohlen noch mal erheblich zunimmt wir
versuchen auch in viele zielgruppen
hineinzukommen bürgerinnen und bürger zu
erreichen die bisher von den
verschiedenen informations aktivitäten
nicht erreicht worden denn es gilt wie
oben drauf steht impfen hilft selbst die
erste impfung schützt vor schwierigen
verläufen wer als wenn man nicht geimpft
ist und das gilt natürlich insbesondere
für all diejenigen die eine musterung
haben deutschland ist dass die im zahlen
betrifft sehr weit gekommen aber nicht
hoch genug wir haben jetzt knapp über 75
prozent der bevölkerung erst kämpft das
muss viel mehr sein und da sind wir auch
schlechter als das verzeichnet werden
kann als in anderen ländern aber wir
sind sehr gut was das boostern betrifft
und deshalb wollen wir beides weiter
voranbringen die auffrischungsimpfung
die erste info
dementsprechend gehört zu unserem spiel
heute gefasst haben die fortgeltung der
bisherigen maßnahmen mit dem was ich
gesagt habe wir haben uns auch
unterhalten über die überregionalen
großveranstaltung wie das weiter
organisiert werden soll und über das
impfen auch darüber gibt es große
einigkeit dass wir die bürgerinnen und
bürger mit dem ausreichend zur verfügung
stehenden impfstoff weiterversorgung
wollen und dass wir alle bitten von der
möglichkeit gebrauch zu machen
es muss und wird getestet werden
angesichts der jetzt schon hohen und
absehbaren noch höheren infektionszahlen
wegen der ansteckenden omikron variante
gilt es jetzt aber eine richtige nutzung
der testmöglichkeiten zu
organisieren dazu haben wir die
gesundheitsministerin
gesundheitsminister der länder zusammen
mit dem bundesminister für gesundheit
gebeten eine bis ins letzte detail
ausbalancierte strategie vorzulegen die
es möglich macht dass wir einen guten
überblick behalten über das
infektionsgeschehen dass wir aber
gleichzeitig all die möglichkeiten die
haben mit pcr test und antigen tests
nutzen um auch möglichst viele
unterstützen zu können
wir haben uns unterhalten der kantine
und in situationen die regelungen sind
verändert worden und werden auch weiter
verändert werden bei uns geht es darum
dass wir hier pragmatisch sind auch da
werden wir uns in den wenn wir uns
weiter mit den fragen beschäftigen wie
das organisiert werden soll sie kennen
die entscheidungen der letzten tage und
der zeit wir haben uns auch mit dem
genesenen und im status beschäftigt da
hat es noch mal eine diskussion gegeben
weil die veränderte rechts und
gesetzeslage dazu geführt hat dass jetzt
entscheidung sehr schnell getroffen
werden können das ist ja einerseits gut
andererseits führt das dazu dass manche
entscheidungen daneben auch für den
einen oder anderen sehr überraschend
kommen und wir haben uns darauf
verständigt dass wir jetzt das so
organisieren wollen das mit den
notwendigen vorkehrungen immer klar ist
man sich rechtzeitig einstellen kann auf
die veränderung die bevorstehenden es
sei eine ganz dramatische entwicklung in
der pandemie dass uns keine wahl aber
das ist ja keine wahrscheinlichkeit
sondern deshalb soll das so sagen
wir sind uns darüber einig dass wir
alles dafür tun müssen die männer und
frauen in den alten einrichtungen für
den pflegeeinrichtungen zu schützen wir
arbeiten weiter daran unsere kritische
infrastruktur stabil zu halten in dieser
zeit und wir haben uns fest vorgenommen
dass wir die digitalisierung des
gesundheitswesens
weiter vorantreiben wollen der experte
das expertengremium das wir eingerichtet
haben hat uns hier weitreichende
vorschläge gemacht die jetzt intensiv
beraten werden es gibt einen großen
konsens darüber dass wir diese
digitalisierung als eine der lehren aus
der korona pandemie und den dingen die
wir besser machen müssen vorantreiben
werden und ich sehe dort eine gemeinsame
anstrengung forums zu der alle bereit
sind dann haben wir noch mal gesagt dass
es weitergehen soll mit
wirtschaftshilfen und kurzarbeitergeld
die uns so weit durch die krise geführt
haben die bundesregierung wird jetzt
ganz zeitnah prüfen was noch
weiterentwickelt was weitergeführt
werden muss so dass wir auch noch den
letzten zeit punkte der krise gut
bewältigen können insgesamt also eine
sehr gute und wie die letzten male auch
nicht allzu lange sich hinziehende
konferenz ein gutes gespräch zwischen
den regierungschefin regierungschefs der
länder untereinander und mit dem
bundeskanzler und der regierung und ich
glaube dass wir da auch gut durch die
krise kommen werden denn das genauso
weitermachen ich bedanke mich sehr bei
dem krisenstab der uns sehr hilft in
hall breuer war erneut dabei und hat
unsere beratung unterstützt ich berate
danke mich ausdrücklich bei dem experten
irgendwie professor krömer hat uns die
dortigen beratung geschildert und uns
damit auch einen wichtigen hinweis für
unsere eigene netz gegeben insgesamt
gilt also kurs halten was das vorsichtig
bleiben in den blick auf kontakte
betrifft kurs halten auch was impfen und
postern betrifft dann haben wir eine
gute chance durch diese schwierige
gesundheitskrise weiter gut
durchzukommen
vielen dank als nächstes der vorsitzende
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz herr
wüst ja viel herzlichen dank fast genau
vor zwei jahren ist corona nach
deutschland gekommen seitdem hat die
pandemie menschenleben gekostet und
viele menschen sehr belastet unser land
befindet sich seit fast zwei jahren
ständigen spirale aus lockdown und
lockerungen und der weg raus aus dieser
spirale führt nur über achtsamkeit
voraussicht und impfung die pandemie ist
derzeit hoch dynamisch
bundesgesundheitsminister hat vor
einigen tagen ein best case szenario
beschrieben nachdem mitte februar ein
peak erreicht werden könnte mit 400.000
infizierten neuinfizierten am tag dazu
kommt jetzt zum zweiten mal in folge zum
zweiten tag in folge
eine höhere belegung der
intensivstationen die experten
expertenrat der bundesregierung hält
auch eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems bei omikron für
möglich der expertenrat hat diese dieser
lage eine klare mahnung ausgesprochen
das infektionsgeschehen erfordert die
beibehaltung und strikte umsetzung der
bisherigen maßnahmen motto länder sind
sich deshalb einig dass die bisher
geltenden regeln grundsätzlich weiterhin
bestand haben wir müssen in den nächsten
wochen aber in beide richtungen blicken
wenn eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems oder der kritischen
infrastruktur droht müssen weitergehende
maßnahmen vereinbart werden andersrum
gilt aber auch bund und länder werden
öffnungs perspektiven entwickeln für den
moment zudem eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystem ausgeschlossen werden
kann
impfungen bleiben der beste weg um unser
gesundheitssystem zu schützen das impfen
ist der weg raus aus der pandemie 85
kite sind der weg zurück zur normalität
für alle die seit zwei jahren sehr unter
dieser pandemie leiden erster stelle
natürlich all die menschen die auf den
intensivstationen
arbeiten die belastet sind überlastet
sind ja und einigen teilen auch wirklich
ausgelaugt und frustriert pflegerinnen
und pfleger ärztinnen und ärzte auch die
eltern die sich sorgen machen ob sie
ihre kinder mit einem guten gefühl in
die kita in die schule schicken können
auch die menschen im angriff in der
gastronomie in der
veranstaltungswirtschaft und anderen
branche die sehr eingeschränkt sind wir
kommen nur heraus aus den ständigen
wiederholung von locker und lockerungen
wenn mehr menschen geimpft sind wir
haben in deutschland aktuell eine
impfquote von 75 prozent das ist
schlicht noch zu wenig der expertenrat
hält deshalb für erforderlich
verbliebene im flecken zu schließen bund
und länder haben deshalb heute
bekräftigt dass sie die vorbereitung
einer allgemeinen impfpflicht für
notwendig halten eine impfpflicht
schützt vor allem besonders gefährdete
menschen und auch diejenigen die sich
nicht impfen lassen können eine
impfpflicht gehört deshalb zu einer
vorausschauenden pandemie politik dazu
für die unionsgeführten bundesländer
habe ich schon in der vergangenen woche
gespräche über die vorbereitung einer
impfpflicht angeboten denn die länder
werden ja vermutlich bei der umsetzung
eine wichtige rolle spielen müssen den
bundeskanzler sehr dankbar dass er
dieses angebot heute auch angenommen hat
und er dafür sorgen möchte dass diese
gespräche zwischen bundesregierung in
fraktionen im bundestag und den ländern
stattfinden können wir sind zu einer
konstruktiven zusammenarbeit gerne
bereit denn unser land ist immer dann am
stärksten wenn wir über alle staatlichen
ebenen hinweg und länder und auch die
kommunen sollen dabei nicht vergessen
werden eng zusammenarbeiten
ein breiter konsens im bundestag
und bundesrat zu diesem thema
impfpflicht kann auch die akzeptanz in
dieser wichtigen maßnahme deutlich
der wollte auch über die tabs strategie
gesprochen die hohe zahl von
neuinfektionen führt zu engpässen bei
der verfügbarkeit von pcr test der
gesundheitsminister die
gesundheitsminister haben deshalb eine
priorisierung beschlossen aus unserer
sicht muss gleichzeitig aber auch daran
gearbeitet werden die pcr test kapazität
schnellstmöglich zu erhöhen das erwarten
die bürgerinnen und bürger zu recht
insbesondere mit blick auf nachbarländer
die da deutlich größere kapazitäten
vorhalten da helfen jetzt keine
schuldzuweisungen in die eine wie die
andere richtig richtung wichtig ist dass
wir an der lage arbeiten dass das besser
wird und deshalb ist gut was der
gesundheitsminister zugesagt hat auch an
der ausweitung der test kapazitäten zu
arbeiten haben heute auch über die
festlegung zum genesenen status und zum
impfstatus gesprochen bund und länder
haben in der vorvergangenen woche
gemeinsam beschlossen dass das robert
koch institut und das paul ehrlich
institut in im status und den genesenen
status näher bestimmen dürfen bundesrat
das am 14 januar beschlossen hat dem
zugestimmt einen tag später hat das lka
die dauer des genesenen status dann
kurzfristig und unangekündigt von 180
tage auf 90 tage verkürzt das hat viele
menschen überrascht und verunsichert
alle länder und zwar parteiübergreifend
waren sich heute einig dass sich das
nicht wiederholen darf es war wichtig
dass der bundesgesundheitsminister
heute zugesagt hat entsprechende
vorkehrungen für die zukunft zu treffen
solche änderungen brauchen einen
angemessenen vorlauf die menschen müssen
sich darauf vorbereiten können eine
vorausschauende politik gerät eben auch
verlässlichkeit
omikron hat die pandemie verändert die
mutation erfordert von uns allen größte
wachsamkeit wir müssen in den nächsten
wochen die entwicklung aller parameter
ganz genau beobachten und bei bedarf
schnell reagieren bund und länder werden
sich in diesem format spätestens 16
februar wieder treffen wenn es vorher
entscheidungsbedarf gibt bin ich sicher
dass wir auch in der lage sind früher
zusammen zu kommen vielen dank
dann als drittes berlins regierende
bürgermeisterin von uns das gefallen ja
meine damen und herren sehr geehrter
herr bundeskanzler sehr geehrter herr
kollege wüst unser
letztendlich motto für heute es geht um
wieder lockern noch verschärfen sondern
ja schon gesagt um groß halten es geht
darum dass wir uns einig waren dass eine
lockerung der maßnahmen zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt mit den entsprechenden
infektionszahlen nicht das mittel der
wahl ist das aber auch in anhand der
empfehlungen des expertenrates eine
weitere verschärfung nicht angezeigt ist
und mir ist wichtig dabei dass die
diskussion der letzten tage die wir auch
aus berlin und von seiten verschiedener
länder eingebracht haben um letztendlich
den dreiklang aus dem schutz der
kritischen infrastruktur der
überarbeitung der kontakt nach
verfolgung der stärkeren fokussierung
fokussierung der kontakt nach verfolgung
und der veränderung des test regimes
heute eingang in diese beschlussfassung
gefunden ich finde es gut dass wir uns
verständigen konnten es gerade bei der
kritischen infrastruktur wir in allen
ländern und dem bund gemeinsam eben mit
den betreibern der kritischen
infrastrukturen ein kontinuierliches
monitoring nicht nur einführen sondern
auch eben entsprechend bedarfsgerecht
weiterentwickeln
wir haben schon jetzt in vielen
bereichen der kritischen infrastruktur
ja eine sehr genaue planung und
vorbereitung auf die pandemie folgen
auch die vorbereitung auf einen starken
personalausfall dass es heute noch
einmal bekräftigt worden dass eben dort
auch die pläne angepasst werden müssen
und getroffene maßnahme eben auch dazu
beitragen die grundversorgung der
bevölkerung aufrecht zu erhalten das ist
bisher gelungen und das so ist auch
unser ganz großes ziel dass der schutz
der kritischen infrastruktur und das
entsprechende monitoring- in all den
bereichen von der strom wasserversorgung
über ernährung und auch was die
rettungsdienste feuerwehr polizei und so
weiter angeht dass das aufrechterhalten
bleibt genauso wie die gesundheitliche
versorgung deswegen ist gut dass sich
heute eben auch nochmal auf den fokus
monitoring- geeinigt worden ist zum
zweiten das thema test regime es ist
ganz klar dass mit den erhöhten zahlen
wir eben nicht mehr einfach genauso
weiter testen wie wir das bisher getan
haben dass es eine fokussierung braucht
eine schwerpunktsetzung bei den pcr
tests auf diejenigen die mit den ganz
besonders von arabien gruppen arbeiten
das betrifft die krankenhäuser das
betrifft die pflegeeinrichtung aber auch
die
eingliederungshilfe und die
einrichtungen der eingliederungshilfe
und hier geht es eben darum dass die pcs
vor allen dingen dort verwendet werden
wo diese gruppen mit anderen
wohlhabenden personen arbeiten und das
gern ansonsten eben ein test regime
erarbeiten das tatsächlich auch die den
einsatz und die anerkennung der antigen
schnittes entsprechend
verwirklicht und zwar wichtig dass wir
das eben heute nicht einfach in der mpk
abschließend besprechen sondern dass der
bundesminister für gesundheit in
abstimmung mit den gesundheitsministerin
und ministern der länder hier ein
verändertes test regime ausarbeiten wird
und das ist eine nationale test
strategie mit der entsprechenden
anpassung der korona virus test
verordnung anhand der neuen
gegebenheiten gibt und gleichzeitig herr
kollege wüst hat das ja schon gesagt
eben alle bemühungen alle anstrengungen
unternommen werden um die pcr test
kapazitäten zu erhöhen und auszuweiten
und der dritte bereich das thema kontakt
nachverfolgung auch hier ist ganz klar
dass wir bei den zahlen unter denen wir
im moment sind auch gerade in den großen
städten in den sehr dicht besiedelten
lagen wir eine kontakt nach verfolgung
durch die gesundheitsämter so wie wir
sie bisher kannten nicht fortführen
können werden sondern dass es um eine
fokussierte kontakt nachverfolgung gehen
muss auch entsprechend der quarantäne
regeln die wir schon getroffen haben und
auch hier ist verständigt worden dass
die regierungschefinnen und
regierungschefs der länder die konferenz
der gesundheitsministerin und
gesundheitsminister eben bitten hier
zeitnah in zusammenarbeit mit dem robert
koch-institut umsetzbare neue regelung
zu erarbeiten damit entsprechend auch
die kontakt nachverfolgung darauf
konzentriert werden kann
erstens was leicht weise und zweitens
natürlich auch auf die wohngruppen zielt
wir haben uns darüber hinaus dazu
verständigt dass es sehr wichtig ist
dass auch die an die eigenverantwortung
der bürgerinnen und bürger noch einmal
appelliert wird nicht nur was das impfen
angeht sondern auch was die
eigenverantwortliche
kommunikation mit kontaktpersonen angeht
was die verwendung elektronischer
hilfsmittel zur kontakt nach vorziehung
angeht ich glaube das ist sehr wichtig
dass wir alle jeder einzelne von uns
sein und ihren beitrag leistet sollte
man selbst an sich symptom oder ein
positiv test
vorliegen haben das dann eben auch
persönlich in eigenverantwortung die
notwendigen schritte ergriffen werden
ich will noch mal verstärken zum thema
impfen wir können sagen dass über die
hälfte der deutschen bevölkerung
mittlerweile gepustet ist dass es eine
sehr gute entwicklung wir sehen hier
auch ein schnelles vorangehen das müssen
wir weiter ausbauen deswegen ist diese
impfkampagne die herr bundeskanzler
vorgestellt hat natürlich auch für
unsere kommunikation in den ländern sehr
hilfreich und wir werden alles daran
setzen dass entsprechend voranzubringen
berlin hat ja auch das buch sein aber
auch auf die impfung von kindern und
jugendlichen einen ganz großen
schwerpunkt gesetzt wir konnten sehr
sehr große zahlen damit schon erreichen
und setzen auch weiterhin eben auf das
aufsuchende impfen auf das kinder und
familien impfen damit wir eben menschen
auch dort erreichen wo sie sind und auch
diejenigen erreichen die wir bisher noch
nicht erreichen konnten ich finde
wichtig dass wir heute sehr klar auf
gesagt haben zu den konkreten einzel
details gibt es verabredung mit den
fachexperten mit dem
gesundheitsministerinnen und ministern
um eben ein neues konzept für die
kontakt nachverfolgung und für das test
regime auszuarbeiten wir denken dass das
sehr zeitnah passieren würde dass es
dann auch die entsprechende orientierung
dafür gibt insofern
haben wir heute sehr konkrete
verabredungen getroffen und auch sehr
einvernehmlich getroffen und das auch in
einem zeitraum der glaube ich absolut
vertretbar ist insofern möchte ich auch
danken einen kolleginnen und kollegen
die heute dazu beigetragen haben dass
wir diese vereinbarung auch treffen
könnten
vielen dank das habe ich schon eine
ganze reihe von fragen und ich beginne
mit kristina dunz vom bnd und danach
andreas kinos vom zdf vielen dank eine
nachfrage zunächst an herrn wüst sie
haben gesagt es geht nicht um
schuldzuweisungen bei dem mangel an test
kapazitäten aber woran hat es gelegen
ist das noch in der verantwortung des
früheren cdu bundesgesundheitsministerin
sparen der ist nicht mehr geschafft hat
oder karl lauterbach von der spd der es
noch nicht geschafft hat oder warum
haben andere länder mehr kapazitäten als
wir und herr bundeskanzler
wenn ich das jetzt auf die schnelle in
dem beschluss gesehen habe ist eine
formulierung nicht drin bei der
digitalisierung des gesundheitssystems
da ging es um die systematische
erfassung datenerfassung zur impfung
verbirgt sich dahinter ein impf register
oder warum gibt es protokollerklärung zb
aus baden württemberg die das explizit
nochmal einfordern vielen dank
von uns wenn ich sage dass ich mich als
schuldzuweisung nicht beteiligen will
dann meine ich das auch so als einfach
jetzt nichts bringen der blick nach
vorne hilft das mag in der vergangenheit
systemische entscheidung gegeben haben
die jetzt kapazitätseinschränkungen
sozusagen systemische bedingen das mag
alles sein wir haben auch sehr gesetzt
auch die schnelltests die den
steuerzahler auch eine menge geld
gekostet haben in den vergangenen
monaten
jetzt sind die pcr tests wir brauchen
mehr und wir sind uns alle einig dass
wir uns da anstrengend
sondern diese anstrengung werden derzeit
unternommen das geht ja darum auch
private unternehmen davon zu überzeugen
dass sie ihre kapazitäten ausweiten
anders als in anderen ländern das nicht
immer privatwirtschaftlich organisiertes
ist dass unsere aufgabe und daran hat
sich der bundesminister für gesundheit
auch gemacht die
konkrete frage betrifft die
digitalisierung des gesundheitswesens
die wollen wir voranbringen das
expertengremium wird und sehr klar
gesagt wir sollten jetzt all das was wir
in dieser pandemie gelernt haben nutzen
um einen großen digitalisierung schub
für das gesamte gesundheitswesen auf den
weg zu bringen insbesondere natürlich
auch im zusammenhang mit dem was man
für eine pandemie braucht aber nicht nur
und ganz klar sind sich alle und darum
sind die vernehmung auch so ausgefallen
wie sie sind das die frage einer
impfpflicht über die wir auch schon
diskutiert haben sich nicht verknüpft
mit dieser frage ob er welche
digitalisierung schritte wir haben
einzelnen vornehmen wollen und deshalb
gibt es hier zügig voran und da wollte
keiner falsche assoziationen setzen ihre
nachfrage hat wahrscheinlich alle
belehrt dass das vielleicht eine gute
idee war
es ist klar dass wir digitalisierung
brauchen wir das konkret gemacht wird
darüber wird jetzt mit vielen experten
experten gesprochen und es ist eine
debatte die sich überhaupt nicht mit dem
anderen thema verknüpft das ja in jedem
fall etwas ist das man über längere zeit
aufbauen muss und wo es darum geht die
perfekte lösung zu finden die uns den
notwendigen informationen liefert und
gleichzeitig den
sicherheit der bürger und bürger und
ihres nachbarn sich
künast
bundeskanzlerin herr wüst hat gerade
über
parteiübergreifende kritik berichtet
darüber wie die verkürzung des genesenen
status von sechs auf drei monate
kommuniziert wurde oder besser gesagt
nicht kommuniziert wurde sie haben jetzt
gesagt ist müsse in zukunft zeit sein
sich darauf einzustellen wie viel zeit
ist damit gemeint in der
beschlussvorlage war von zwei wochen die
rede ist dass jetzt auch das worauf sie
sich geeinigt haben und haben sie ihren
gesundheitsminister gegen die
parteiübergreifende kritik von der herr
wüst spricht in dieser sitzung
verteidigt heute es gab eine
solidarische diskussion war die sich vor
allem nach vorne gerichtet unterhalten
haben deshalb ist es auch so dass wir
keine konkrete zeitperspektive für die
frage welchem vorlauf brauchen sie für
jede einzelne entscheidung genannt haben
weil das in jedem einzelfall sehr
unterschiedlich sein kann es kann und
mit er aber nicht rechnen situationen
geben die erfordern das sofort gar nicht
werden muss aber sofort auch alle
informiert werden auch alle politischen
entscheidungsträger weil sich dramatisch
etwas ändert das keinen aufschub kostet
ein aufschub erlaubt und es kann
situationen geben wo wir durchaus noch
die zeit haben einen vorlauf prozess zu
organisieren der aber sich dann auch
jeweils aus der natur der sache ergibt
und in dieser pragmatischen und
konstruktiven weise ist die diskussion
dann zu einem gemeinsamen beschluss
vorangekommen
der bundesgesundheitsminister hat von
mir die unterstützung bekommen die er
braucht und die auch kriegen muss weil
er ein ganz großartiger minister ist und
in dieser frage hoch engagiert und es
hat eigentlich jeder gesagt dass er sehr
engagiert diese arbeit macht ich glaube
sogar parteiübergreifend lässt sich das
festhalten insofern war ich vielleicht
geht man das besonders gerne gemacht hat
aber viele andere auch noch
die kollegin dahinter
die hauptstadtstudio ich grüße sie eine
frage zur beschluss zum beschluss da
drinsteht dass beim überregionalen
großveranstaltungen einheitliche regeln
beschlossen werden oder gesprochen
werden sollen heißt das also welche
richtung soll das gehen heißt das gibt
es jetzt einheitlich bundesweit mehr
zuschauer bei fußballspielen oder
weniger
und die frage was heißt denn lockerungen
es wird schon eine öffnung perspektive
gesprochen ein ende von 2g eine masken
pflicht ein ende wird dann vielleicht
irgendwann wieder eine normalität wie
vor der pandemie eintreten
was die letzte frage betrifft hoffen wir
alle arbeiten wir alle hart daran dass
wir meine unsere lebenswirklichkeit vor
der pandemie wiederfinden werden klar
werden wir all das was wir jetzt gelernt
haben nicht vergessen insbesondere die
gefahr dass die welt in der wir leben
immer wieder solche
dramatischen negativen überraschungen
für uns bereit halten kann und auch neue
viren neuinfektionen einfluss nehmen
können unser leben nicht nur hierzulande
sondern der ganzen welt und darf müssen
wir uns natürlich gut vorbereitet
trotzdem wir wollen wieder zudem leben
vor der pandemie zurückkehren darum geht
es ja bei all dem was wir an anstrengung
unternehmen und gleichzeitig gilt was
ich und auch die beiden die ihr neben
mir sitzen schon gesagt haben wir wollen
jetzt nicht den eindruck erwecken als ob
das jetzt der moment für lockerung wäre
das ist ja nicht jetzt geht es um kurs
halten wir haben infektionszahlen die
höher sind als für sie sehr sehr als wir
sie bisher überhaupt verzeichnet haben
wir wissen dass diese infektionszahlen
noch höher werden dass also die ansteckt
das an die ansteckende natur des mikros
dazu führen wird dass wir möglicherweise
sogar einmal daten mit mehreren
hunderttausend einstecken und einem tag
erleben und deshalb ist das jetzt nicht
der moment wo man sagt ja ja sondern das
ist der moment wo man kurz hält klar ist
dass wenn wir mehr wissen
land sehen wenn wir wissen wo wir
hinkommen werden wie wir durch die
situation kommen und sich die lage
entspannt dann auch über entscheidung
getroffen werden kann sowie lockerungen
vornehmen können das ist dann
darüber haben sich die
ministerpräsidenten
ministerpräsidenten intensiv unterhalten
und sind zu dem gemeinsamen ergebnis
gekommen ich glaube das kann man
zusammenfassen dass sie dort
gemeinsam bezahlen und werte kommen
werden
michael fischer dpa als nächstes und
danach cerstin gammelin
ja vielen dank herr bundeskanzler
sie haben gerade selbst den schleppenden
fortschritt erwähnt sie haben sich für
ende januar zwei ziele gesetzt dazu
einmal 30 millionen impfungen seit dem
dezember
und eine impfquote von 80 prozent bei
den erst impfungen wir sind jetzt gleich
bei ungefähr 15 millionen impfungen und
75,5 prozent bei den erste impfungen
glauben sie dass ihre ziele noch
erreichbar sind und was bedeutet ist für
die die impfpflicht für die debatte über
die impfpflicht die jetzt ansteht
und wenn sie erlauben noch eine frage
zum thema ukraine die eu-außenminister
haben heute der ukraine unterstützung
bei der militärausbildung in aussicht
gestellt wäre deutschland bereit sich
daran zu beteiligen
also zunächst mal ist es so dass wir
einen fortschritt haben der nicht gut
genug ist wir sind wie sie gesagt haben
bei erstimpfung jetzt bei knapp über 75
prozent der bevölkerung wir müssten viel
höher liegen wir haben das ziel weiter
voranzukommen das geschieht auch aber
nicht in dem tempo das notwendig wäre
und was die auffrischungsimpfung
betrifft ist es so dass wir
uns vorgenommen haben dass wir hier
auch weiter vorankommen wir hatten vor
weihnachten zahlen mit über einer
million impfungen am tag das ist
gegenwärtig nicht der fall und deshalb
werden unsere anstrengungen verstärkt
werden müssen damit wir weiter
vorankommen mein ziel bleibt dass wir
all diejenigen die schon eine
auffrischungsimpfung haben erreichen die
schon eine zweite impfung haben die
schon vollständigen impfschutz an
erreichen dass sie sich eine
auffrischungsimpfung holen das heißt das
ziel mit den 60 millionen bleibt man
muss realistisch sein das werden wir
nicht mehr zielgerecht erreichen und dem
tag den ich mir das wünschen würde aber
wir haben durchaus die chance das ziel
zu erreichen und deshalb gilt es jetzt
hier auch entsprechend voranzukommen
darum auch die kampagne und ansonsten
ist es so dass wir natürlich
unterstützung zur verfügung stellen dass
es ja auch in der vergangenheit der fall
und die einzige sache die wir immer sehr
klar gesagt haben so wie auch die
frühere bundesregierung ist wie liefern
keine digitalen offen ansonsten hat das
kooperation unterstützung in der
vergangenheit gegeben und wird es auch
in zukunft gegeben auch mit unserem mit
ihm zusammen
ich würde gern einmal grundsätzlich
angehen lassen sie haben ja heute kurz
bevor die
pressekonferenz angefangen hat hat man
gehört dass in berlin die präsenzpflicht
an schulen ausgesetzt wird sie haben
ausgeführt dass zu wenig tester sind das
priorisiert wird die arbeitgeber
beschwerten sich dass sie jetzt nicht
mehr wissen auf welcher grundlage sie
möglicherweise entgelte zahlen können
und
die kontakt verfolgung bei den
gesundheitsämtern ist quasi aufgegeben
ist das jetzt nicht alles auch ein
eingeständnis dass sie die kontrolle
über die pandemie verloren haben und die
jetzt in den nächsten wochen durch
rauschen wird
nein aber es ist ein hinweis darauf und
deshalb bin ich ihnen für die folge auch
sehr dankbar dass wir sehr hohe
infektionszahlen haben infektionszahlen
wie wir sie bisher nicht gekannt haben
wo wir schon mal ein bisschen zu schauen
konnten die sich das entwickeln wird in
unseren nachbarländern weil die ja
weniger strenge regeln was kontakt
beschränkt und betrifft ergriffen haben
und deshalb auch viel früher mit höheren
infektionszahlen durch das omikron wir
uns konfrontiert worden sind wir haben
diese zeit nutzen können dafür dass wir
weitermachen mit dem impfen dass wir bei
den auffrischungsimpfungen sicherlich
vorne anliegen in der europäischen union
und das wollen wir auch weitermachen und
auch wenn unsere eigenen ehrgeizigen
ziele dabei noch nicht erreicht sind
bleibt das ja dabei dass wir diese ziele
verfolgen aus gutem grund der hat
nämlich was mit den hohen
infektionszahlen zu tun und natürlich
muss man dann in einer konkreten
situation sich jeweils auf die situation
einstellen also die hohen
infektionszahlen führen dazu dass die
art und weise wie wir kann themen der
regeln festlegen sich verändern müssen
allerdings auch unsere wachsenden
erkenntnisse darüber wann eine kantine
verlassen werden kann wer da wir haben
zum beispiel auch die möglichkeiten die
sich dadurch ergeben dass
kontaktpersonen gebucht sind das nutzen
wir auch und das gleiche gilt für die
verschiedenen anderen entscheidungen die
wir im hinblick aufs priorisierung zu
treffen haben und über die nutzung der
konkreten test sie erforderlich sind
meine these ist also das ist eine große
herausforderung und bleibt auch eine all
diejenigen die das jetzt klein reden und
sagen das sind zwar hohe
infektionszahlen aber es ist nichts los
haben sich recht aber wir haben glaube
ich schon eine lage in der bund und
länder die richtigen entscheidungen
treffen können und auch die angemessene
entscheidungen für die konkrete sind
wird
ich würde gern was ergänzen schulischen
situation für uns ist und ich glaube das
ist sehr wichtig dass wir das auch noch
mal klar machen wir haben uns ja in der
mpk darauf verständigt dass die
schulischen fragen in den jeweiligen
bundesländern geklärt werden anhand auch
das konkreten infektionsgeschehen in der
kultusminister zuständigkeit der länder
für uns und für mich ist es ganz wichtig
dass wir aufrechterhalten der schulische
angebot das alle kinder und jugendlichen
in die schule gehen können dass die
schulen geöffnet sind dass sie die
möglichkeit haben eben gut gebildet gut
betreut zu sein ein regelmäßiges
mittagessen zu bekommen und auch
entsprechend einen test zu bekommen wir
sehen aber in der situation die wir
haben mit den zunehmenden steigenden
zahlen dass wir auch eltern haben die
sich sorgen machen und die gerne diese
entscheidung ob sie ihr kind in die
schule schicken oder nicht auch selbst
treffen möchten und diese
diese entscheidung die wir jetzt
getroffen haben zu sagen wir setzen
temporär die präsenzpflicht in den
berliner schulen aus bis ende februar
die basiert auf der erklärung der
als ärzte in den gesundheitsämtern dass
sie eben eine kontakt nach verfolgung in
einen über 800 touren bei über 300.000
schülerinnen und schülern nicht mehr so
nach voll verfolgen nachvollziehen
können und in diesem moment wo wir eine
solche situation haben solche fallzahlen
haben ist eben auf der einen seite für
uns wichtig dass wir den schulbetrieb
aufrecht erhalten dass es ein angebot
weiter gibt aber dass gleichzeitig auch
den eltern die möglichkeit eingeräumt
wird werden sie es möchten und für sich
und ihr kind entscheiden wie sich eine
ausnahme von dieser präsenz aufzunehmen
und das ganz unkompliziert ab morgen
auch machen zu können trotzdem ist für
uns wichtig die schulen bleiben offen
dass präsenz angebot ist das
regelangebot auch weiterhin es gibt die
möglichkeit davon abzuweichen
aber ich glaube das ist einfach jetzt
ein weg um den verschiedenen
bedürfnissen die wir hier an dieser
stelle sehen kinderbetreuung
aufrechterhalten auf der anderen seite
den sorgen der eltern zu entsprechen
auch hier gerecht zu werden und das ist
ein zeichen von reaktion sofort die
reaktion auf eine veränderte lage und
das ist glaube ich das was auch von uns
erwartet würden das hat nichts mit
kontrollverlust zu tun sondern damit
dass wir einfach gezwungen sind auf die
sich aktuell ändernde entwicklung auf zu
reagieren und einzugehen so dass es für
möglichst viele in der bevölkerung auch
ein gangbarer weg ist und darum geht es
an der stelle
ja noch ein paar nachfragen auch an den
bundeskanzler die nachfrage
würden sie sagen dass sie trotz dieser
sagen wir mal eigenverantwortlich
handelnden infizierten bürger trotz
mangelnder test trotz rudimentäre
kontakt verfolgung die übersicht über
die infektionszahlen beiden werden
dafür sind heute die notwendigen
entscheidungen getroffen worden genau
das passiert darum haben wir das
expertengremium dann haben wir den
krisenstab darum nehmen wir die
ratschläge an und darum gibt es die
entscheidung die zum beispiel die
gesundheitsministerin minister der
länder mit dem bundesgesundheitsminister
getroffen haben wir jetzt auch hier sich
in dem beschluss mit den verschiedenen
stellen wieder fällt es ist die richtige
reaktion auf eine veränderte lage und
das ist gut dass das so einvernehmlich
so koordiniert so gut vorbereitet und so
lange diskutiert geschieht weil das die
voraussetzung dafür ist dass wir
jederzeit das richtige in der lage tun
könnten
andreas rinke und danach vegetieren
ich danke schön eine frage sowohl an den
kanzler als auch an helm grüßt und zwar
zu dem passus wo es auch um mögliche
verschärfung geht wenn eine überlastung
des gesundheitssystems droht so die
formulierung woran wird das genau
gemessen werden also haben sie da
bestimmte indikatoren die sie dann dafür
heranziehen oder sollen die
krankenhäuser erst etwas flapsig gesagt
verlaufen wie der expertenrat das jahr
prognostiziert und herr bundeskanzler
auch eine frage zu kleine das weiße haus
hat bekannt gegeben dass sie nachher an
einer videoseite teilnehmen mit
europäischen staats und regierungschefs
und dem us-präsidenten ist das ein
zeichen dafür dass die lage so
besorgniserregend geworden ist dass sie
über notfall und sanktionsmaßnahmen
nachdenken müssen
zur zweiten frage die lage ist ernst
aber nicht erst heute sondern seinen
vielen vielen tagen wochen und monaten
schon und deshalb ist es auch wichtig
dass wir in dieser frage alle einig und
geschlossen handeln und dazu gehört dass
wir sagen es darf nicht zu einer
verletzung der territorialen integrität
eines staates in europa kommen das gilt
ganz besonders auch für die ukraine
und wir werden das auch nicht hinnehmen
und falls es zu einer solchen situation
kommt werden wir gemeinsam reagieren das
würde hohe kosten haben
aber es gehört auch zu dieser situation
dass wir sie immer wieder gemeinsam
bewerten die lage besprechen und daraus
die nächsten schritte ableiten die wir
mit dem dazu treffen haben insofern ist
das ein gutes zeichen für die enge
zusammenarbeit und die gute kooperation
unter denjenigen die sich hier zusammen
treibt die hier zusammentreffen aber
insgesamt für nato und europäische union
ich glaube dass man das so bewerten
sollte
was die frage betrifft
nach den maßnahmen die ergriffen werden
müssen und woran wir das messen wir
haben doch jetzt eine situation die
hätte ihnen keinen wissenschaftler und
keine wissenschaftlerin als die
situation
am anfang des jahres 2021 vorher gesagt
dass wir sehr hohe infektionszahlen
haben wir in anderen ländern wo sie
teilweise ein paar hunderttausend bürger
pro tag betreffen länder die
vergleichbar sind mit uns da sind wir
nicht angekommen wir sind jetzt aber
über den 100000 auch schon an
verschiedenen tagen gewesen und werden
das auch weiter sein es wird weiter
steigende infektionszahlen geben
trotzdem hätte niemand vorher gesagt
dass mit diesen hohen infektionszahlen
nicht in gleicher weise wie früher eine
belastung der krankenhäuser insgesamt
und insbesondere der intensivstation
verbunden ist bisher wir wissen aber
dass
durch die große zahl der infizierten
das schon eine herausforderung ist und
die auch das gesundheitswesen zukommt
und deshalb ist ja unsere klare
entscheidung wir bereiten uns auf eine
solche situation vor wir können hoffen
dass das verhältnis zwischen infektionen
und intensiv wichtigkeit
so viel geringer ist dass das nicht
passieren wird ihr könnt hoffen dass
unsere fortgesetzte imf und auffrischung
des kampagne mit dem muster im fond dazu
beiträgt dass wir die situation dadurch
entlasten können und deshalb kann
niemand gegenwärtig vorhersagen welche
der verschiedenen möglichen
entwicklungen und tatsächlich in
deutschland eintreten wird aber wir tun
alles dafür dass es diejenigen die die
weniger herausfordernde
situation mit sich bringt dies dann
kommen wird das eis kann er jetzt und
das kann man noch nicht vorhersagen
vielleicht ergänzen darwin noch da noch
sagen dass es ja auch den zweiten faktor
gibt er zu einer belastung des
gesundheitssystems führen kann nämlich
eine große anzahl von erkrankten
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern und
das haben wir natürlich sehr genau im
blick weil die ja tagesaktuell in den
kliniken bekannt sind herr professor
krömer hat das sollte auch für die
charité
berichtet dass man sozusagen tages genau
sagen kann wie viele mitarbeiterinnen
mitarbeiter erkranken wo wir merkt gar
nicht nur im dienst überwiegend sogar je
nach beschäftigung außerhalb des
krankenhauses und beides muss man im
blick haben den anfall von patienten
aber auch den ausfall von
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeitern durch
eigene infektion oder durch garantien
ja ich hatte auch noch mal eine frage
zur eröffnungs perspektive ist denn
schon diskutiert werden welche bereiche
man eventuell als erster schritt öffnen
könnte und dann das der nächste termin
ist der 16 februar
der gesundheitsminister sagt dass dann
ungefähr auch der höhepunkt der pandemie
erreicht sein könnte könnte man denn
dann vielleicht auch schon entscheiden
und man dann in einer lockerung 1 1 geht
wenn man erkennt dass letztendlich da
keine überlastung ist und auch noch mal
eine frage zur ukraine
es gibt ja sicherlich auch unter anderem
auch um die frage ob andere länder
waffen oder auch ausrüstung liefern
estland hatte eben eine solche anfrage
gestellt ist die bundesregierung bereit
letztendlich diese lieferung zu
ermöglichen
sie kennen die entscheidung die
bundesregierung
bei einer kontinuität und hintergangen
waffen die von getroffen hat hier so
etwas andere sachverhalt dennoch geprüft
wird und das dauert auch noch an
was die frage betrifft
der
beschäftigung mit lockerungen das wäre
glaube ich in der gegenwärtigen
situation etwas eigenwillig wenn wir da
konkrete diskussion über konkrete
maßnahmen führen würden denn wir erleben
ja gerade neue hochs oder den
infektionszahlen und wir wissen dass
weitere bugs auf uns zukommen werden sie
selbst haben gerade gesagt dass das zu
sein können dass in die
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten
regierungschef von regierungschefs der
länder mit dem bundeskanzler das nächste
mal zusammenkommen am 16 februar
wahrscheinlich gerade der höhepunkt des
infektionsgeschehen zu verzeichnen ist
nach den berechnungen die gegenwärtig
angestellt werden wie es dann sein wird
wissen wir am 16 februar genauer und
deshalb macht es auch keinen sinn
irgendwelche vorhersagen über das was
wir konkret an dem tag zu beraten haben
zu treffen es gehört schon dazu dass wir
die wirkliche lage betrachten und dann
mit realen entscheidung auf die
wirkliche lage reagieren
burke von der deutschen welle ich möchte
auch zu der ukraine krise vor allem den
bundeskanzler fragen herr bundeskanzler
die äußerungen von dem marine inspekteur
in indien zu der krise in ukraine haben
natürlich für entsetzen gesorgt vor
allem in ukraine er ist natürlich nicht
mehr im amt aber seine äußerungen sind
für viele ausländische betrachter
besonders über beispielsweise in ukraine
grund zur sorge dass seine haltung in
deutschland vielleicht sogar in ihrer
partei weit verbreitet ist deswegen für
das internationale publikum die frage
wie bewerten sie als bundeskanzler
persönlich die ausführungen von kay
achim schönbach und auch also zu dieser
frage bezüglich es land würde ich mich
auch anschließen diese entscheidung
dauert an haben sie gesagt aber was wäre
ihre meinungen also was würden sie sind
sie persönlich dafür oder dagegen
dankeschön
prüfungs entscheidungen sind prüfungs
entscheidungen den sorgfältig die
verschiedenen fragen abgewogen werden
übrigens nicht nur von der deutschen
regierung da sind auch andere dann
beteiligt sogar vor uns und das ist
alles noch ganz am anfang dass wir
darüber jetzt zu diesem zeitpunkt
diskutieren ist eher unwahrscheinlich da
waren einige dicht dran an einem
entscheidungsprozess dann noch nicht mal
begonnen hatte und haben schon über ihn
berichtet das ist natürlich interessant
vielleicht auch für die
selbstbeobachtung aber die zweite frage
die
aussagen die der
vize-admiral gemacht hat entsprechen
nicht den vorstellungen der
bundesregierung und deshalb ist ja auch
seine demission akzeptiert
wie lang
einen guten heimweg
guten heimweg mit den beschlüssen dieses
corona gipfels verkündet vom kanzler von
olaf scholz von berlins regierende
bürgermeisterin franziska gefalle und
von nordrhein westfalens
ministerpräsident hendrik wüst es lässt
ein ein bisschen ratlos zurück war es
hier in diesem papier in diesem
beschluss steht denn wir haben lange
pcr-test schlangen aktuell seit wochen
mittlerweile problemlösung hier drin
nicht wir haben riesenprobleme mit
quarantäne regeln in diesem land so
viele fallen wegen der quarantäne aus
bei der arbeit in der schule ganze
klassen wieder raus kitas geschlossen
usw eine lösung hier nicht drin in
diesem papier stattdessen
arbeitsaufträge prüfaufträge man will
das mal diskutieren man will beraten in
den nächsten wochen usw jan schäfer bild
politikchef das ding löst keine
alltagsprobleme richtig nein das ist
eine ansammlung an banalitäten muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen und
ironisch formuliert ich sagt das extra
also mein lieblingssatz ist der satz auf
seite 3 unter punkt 2 wir haben sie
insgesamt ein papier über sieben seiten
zu tun den sind beschluss heißt es dann
unter punkt 2 geht es um diese so
genannte öffnungs mct iva an bord was
auch die ehemalige bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel immer wieder benutzt hat
öffnungs perspektive bedeute ich rede
über das wort öffnungen ohne dass sich
eigene perspektive schaffe das wort an
sich ist also schon unlogischer steht
ihr wieder drin und dann kommt auch
dieser hammerharte satz achtung ironie
hammerharte satz bund und länder werden
öffnungs perspektive entwickeln für den
moment zudem eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems ausgeschlossen werden
kann dieser satz ist das muss man
wirklich sagen an banalität nicht zu
überbieten da ist überhaupt nichts
konkret ist und ich weiß gar nicht warum
dieser satz hier drin steht und von
diesem satz finden sich in ähnlicher
form hat weitere sätze drinnen auch dass
der bundesgesundheitsminister
aufgefordert wird für mehr tests zu
sorgen ja wie bitte waren diese
auffordern das zu tun er stand ja heute
sowieso im kreuzfeuer der offenbar in
dieser ministerpräsidentenkonferenz bei
diesem corona gipfel karl lauterbach und
jetzt muss man ihn bitten da aktiv zu
werden das heißt als minister heißt sie
ganz klar gleichzeitig müssen alle
anstrengungen unternommen werden die pcr
test kapazitäten zu erhöhen da würde man
das also das ist auch wieder so banal
dass man sagt man hat einen notstand und
natürlich muss dieser notstand behoben
wären dass das an die aufgabe die
kernaufgabe von politik einen notstand
zu beheben dass der nochmals schriftlich
fixiert wird das zeigt dass dieser
gipfel den wir heute gesehen haben so
überflüssig wie ein kropf die frage kam
ja gerade bei dieser pressekonferenz
auch von einer kollegin in diesem fall
cerstin gammelin von der süddeutschen
zeitung nach dem alltagsleben im moment
in der beim job bei der arbeit in den
schulen vor allen dingen während dieser
gipfel läuft während die regierende
bürgermeisterin von berlin franziska
giffey dort saß in dieser video schalte
hat sie mal lässig in ihrem eigenen
bundesland nämlich in berlin die
präsenzpflicht wieder in den schulen
aufgehoben das ist das was im moment
millionen deutsche befürchten wieder
homeschooling wieder home office wieder
raus wieder rein in den lockdown genau
die begründung klingt so hat es
zumindest der franziska giffey gerade
formuliert eigentlich ganz logisch dass
sie sagt ja sie möchte eltern die chance
geben dass sie wenn sie sorge um ihr
kind haben dieses kind zu hause lassen
können das kann man auf der einen seite
verstehen aber es ist ganz klar das
aufheben der präsenzpflicht ein erster
schritt rhein wieder in einen schuh
lockdown es nichts anderes und die große
frage und ich würde ganz viel darauf
wetten die ist mit sicherheit ungeklärt
wie geht es denn jetzt weiter in den
schulen franziska gefahr hat gerade
gesagt das gilt bereits ab morgen in
berlin also ab dienstag und ich würde
wetten dass nicht klar ist wie die
schülerinnen und schüler die jetzt zu
hause bleiben das könnten ab morgen
relativ viele seien schuld sich
eigentlich unterrichtet werden sollen
sehen wir also in den klassen plötzlich
wenn von 30 schülern 10 zu hause sind
eine lehrerin oder ein lehrer der dann
vor einem ipad steht oder einem computer
dass also der unterricht dann nach hause
übertragen wird und ebenso im
klassenraum wie wird das funktionieren
nur als eine aber dass eine kernfrage
also wir werden auch sehen dass das
leistungsniveau und der wissensstand in
den schulklassen natürlich weiter noch
sich verschiebt gute schüler schlechte
schüler welche mit viel bildung welche
den unterricht oft gar nicht mitbekommen
haben und natürlich lädt auch so eine
eine präsenzpflicht die dann aufgehoben
wird zu missbrauchen das ist auch ganz
klar also wir befinden uns beim thema
schulen auf einem ziemlich schlechten
weg öffnungs perspektive das ist also so
ein wort das uns heute geschenkt wird
das deutschland geschenkt wird heute bei
dem man nicht wirklich weiß was es
bedeutet bei dem man aber ganz praktisch
sieht aktuell dass es erstmal keine
lockerung bedeutet werden wir hier
sprechen kündigen die niederlanden
übrigens ganz große breite öffnung
schritte lockerungsschritte für ab
morgen vor eine ganz wichtige frage
aktuell die quarantäne frage da ist
jetzt nicht klar wie geht man aktuell
mit positiven tests eigentlich um
dadurch dass die pcr test priorisiert
werden also vor allen dingen denen in
den krankenhäusern in den pflegeheimen
zur verfügung gestellt werden sollen ab
sofort gelten also dann nicht mehr nur
positive pcr tests als zuhause ticket
sozusagen sondern möglicherweise schon
positive schnelltest das bedeutet noch
mehr menschen ab jetzt in quarantäne ja
ja dass das ist zu befürchten ohne frage
das natürlich jene die sich dann einmal
haben testen lassen positiv sind und ein
zweites mal getestet werden genau und
zwar nicht mit einen pcr-test dann in
quarantäne müssen das ganze wissen aber
auch dass beispielsweise
gebucht hatte also mindestens dreimal
geimpfte mindestens muss man ja
mittlerweile sagen drei mal kämpfte bei
einem direkten kontakt nicht mehr in
quarantäne müssen das gibt also auf der
anderen seite dann entspannt hier ist es
klar es gab noch eine szene bei dieser
pressekonferenz in die wollen wir ganz
kurz reinschauen nämlich die vorstellung
einer neuen werbekampagne das also soll
der impfkampagne noch mal ein bisschen
neuen speed geben denn da ist ordentlich
tempo raus gekommen der kanzler hat
seine im ziele nicht erreicht auch das
war thema heute im corona gipfel nachdem
es im alten jahr 2021 gut anlief erst
mal hat er heute dieses plakat
hochgehalten das ist also das monetär
und womit der
gesundheitsminister die sich geimpft
wurde doch noch deutlich als ich eben
solcher also impfen hilfen auch allen
die du liebst jetzt mal ganz ehrlich ist
ja es gibt eben millionen deutsche die
sich bis heute nicht haben eben
verlassen da sind jetzt ganz
individuelle gründe spielen eine rolle
möglicherweise auch ein bisschen trotz
wird man da sich von einer solchen
werbekampagne jetzt auf der zielgeraden
ganz realistisch gefragt überzeugen
lassen gegenfrage würdest du dich
überzeugen lassen von dieser
impfkampagne ich kann es mir ganz schwer
vorstellen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt diese
frage noch mit nein beantwortet zu haben
aber ich glaube ich würde in diesem fall
natürlich diese werbekampagne nicht um
steht vielleicht denken wir uns das
einfach ein bisschen zu statisch der
neue regierungssprecher steffen
hebestreit hat ja bei seiner ersten
pressekonferenz angekündigt dass der
bundeskanzler künftig auch tik tok
tanzen soll vielleicht hat diese
werbekampagne erfolg vielleicht gibt es
so etwas wie einen tick tock tanz den
olaf scholz oder karl lauterbach und wir
sehen das im rahmen der werbekampagne
ich weiß es nicht aber möglicherweise
hat sie dann erfolgt also das jedenfalls
das neue plakat der bundesregierung die
neue werbekampagne die auf der
zielgeraden nochmal die impfquote in die
höhe treiben soll sie hat der kanzler
olaf scholz heute vorgestellt das war
bildpolitik chef jan schäfer zu den
ergebnissen dieses corona gipfels der
nicht allzu viele ergebnisse leider für
ihren alltag eine erleichterung für ihn
alltag leider gebracht hat